expliquez moi comment on peut trouver
deux sûrement france est vendu à 300
mille exemplaires il est sorti hier
janvier 2004 guillaume musso professeur
en économie est déjà présenté comme un
phénomène littéraire le succès de son
deuxième livre et après et immédiat
auprès des lecteurs depuis trois mois
mon livre a été choisi pour être l'avant
première d'un club de livre qui
s'appelle france loisirs way et donc
voilà on a déjà vendu 350 mille
exemplaires et donc il est sorti en
librairie hier nous sommes riches pas
riche mais est riche de lecteurs et ses
lecteurs sont de plus en plus nombreux
guillaume musso écrivain prolifique
tient la cadence d'un nouveau roman
chaque année en 2006 il passait la barre
du million d'exemplaires vendus
mais pas question pour l'auteur de
parler de célébrités j'aime que les gens
aiment mes livres j'aime que les gens
m'écrivent me disent que mes histoires
leur ont apporté du bonheur mais la
notoriété en tant que telle non c'est
pas trop trop mon truc
la recette de l'écrivain une écriture
simple et haletante pour décrire son
univers un mélange de thriller de roman
d'amour et de fantastique
en 2008 les ingrédients sont les mêmes
et son sixième roman fait partie des
best-sellers qu'il est passionnant
les faits révélés c'est du surnaturel
c'est de l'étrange on n'est pas dans la
vie de tous les jours on va il fait
rêver
cette année là l'auteur culmine à 3 5
millions de livres vendus en france et
il est traduit en 23 langues
l'un de ses romans et même adapté au
cinéma la carrière de guillaume musso
est à présent internationale mais c'est
toujours en tant qu'écrivain populaire
qu'il préfère être présenté moi je suis
un pur produit du bouche à oreille mais
mes romans ont eu du succès parce que
les gens et non pas la presse se les
sont appropriés seul et son conseiller
huit ans plus tard en 2010 est l'auteur
en est à son quatorzième roman et auprès
de ses lecteurs la magie opère toujours
c'est très agréable à lire voilà donc ça
prouve que c'est bien écrit à tout à
fait bien si ça se libère
je pense que je vais à peu près tout
celui là je vais le lire pour commencer
les histoires d'amour qu'il est riche
que c'est super joli pas vraiment
aujourd'hui 16 ans après son premier
succès guillaume musso fait partie des
auteurs français les plus lus dans le
monde avec plus de 35 millions de livres
vendus en 2019
en france il était numéro 1 des ventes
pour la huitième année consécutive
l'histoire d'un professeur d'économie
devenu auteur à succès
[Musique]